the government hopes that tough
enforcement of the rules
will stop the spread of the virus so
what does the data tell us about the
scale of non-compliance
this chart shows the number of journeys
planned on apple maps in the last year
and you can see it plummeted during the
first lockdown
and then over here it fell again during
the second lockdown
it's now at its lowest point since april
which is roughly what you'd expect given
the strictness of the rules
a lot more things open now than they
were then
of course this data doesn't tell us
where people were traveling to
whether going to illegal raves or
dropping their kids off at nursery
for that we can use survey data and
fortunately we have an amazing resource
the covet 19 social study which
regularly asks more than 70
000 people about their experience of
lockdown
these are the headline results on
compliance
and this yellow line here represents
complete compliance
basically more than half of people say
they follow the rules
all the time this blue line up here is
majority compliance
it's really high 96 percent because
almost
everyone says they follow the rules
almost
all the time the gap between the two is
where people
bend the rules and add their own tweaks
and modifications
and yeah there's definitely quite a bit
of that but stepping back
this is a picture of really good
compliance and in fact
due to recent rises compliance is now at
its
highest level since april
now not everyone complies in the same
way
and i just want to highlight one fact
for you there's so much interesting
detail here for example
men comply much less than women but this
is really important
key workers say they comply 49 of the
time that is
10 percentage points less than non-key
workers
now that is something the government
really might look at especially now the
definition of key worker
is so much bigger thanks to this amazing
study we also have data on which
rules people break the yellow bit here
is when people say they never follow a
particular rule
and you can see the rules that people
are most likely to break
are meeting up outdoors and also
meeting up indoors which is let's know
much more dangerous but again
the important thing here isn't the small
amount of yellow
it's this very large amount of green
the data suggests that most people are
following the rules
it does make you wonder how much effect
will cracking down the small minority
have
on the spread of the virus compared to
just changing the rules
for everyone